in terms of writing and great scene what
do you feel is your strongest scene for
tonight's nomination you remember one
scene in particular that you're really
proud of Dina meant the most to me was
you know show me a hero there's a
lottery to figure out who gets to live
in this townhouse was there were
billions in the middle of a whole lot of
controversy and I loved writing the
scene because it was the scene that
brought me into the book it was the
first time that I met any of the people
who became the main characters and it
means a lot to me do you feel you're
writing more today than you have already
getting I enjoyed i am writing
constantly i think that if you're right
now you have to write constantly because
there's just this appetite for
everything all the time here sorry
that's my producer 00 we finna load her
up um I write every day am i right more
than I ever get yeah i think that
there's an endless appetite now for
writing and so it's not like i get to
eventually it's a 24-7 kind of business
like every other day you okay do you
have a specific time that you wrote
thank you
I always wanted to be one of those
people who gets up early and there's 10
nights down and is focused and and every
morning I swear I'm going to be but no I
have no schedule that I've ever managed
to make work for me it just do you feel
you have to be inspired to write or do
you force yourself to sit down when when
writers may I do for a living you can't
wait transpiration get your butt in the
chair and the start and that's that
should be inspiring do you rest your
writing mind by doing something else
creative like I watched the documentary
is Joni Mitchell and I talked about
painting versus singing she almost has
to take it or she'll get 68 it's gelatin
it's where your kind of conjugating and
in one corner of your brain and it's
doing sign and we different than I mean
for me it's getting up and walking the
dog what I really can't figure out how
something starts I get up and I take a
shower you yes it's it's standing up and
doing something different is when you
usually figure out what the heck it is
you've been working on and lastly
provide you keep yourself from
procrastinate are there certain tricks
that we use to watch yourself out of
that mode how do you counter cell for
procrastinating you figure it out please
let me know gang on what I haven't for
instance going on social media or
straight your web getting going down a
rabbit hole of something that you want
to research deadlines I'm a journalist I
mean that but I'm a journalist by
training and so I am deadline-driven and
I will
put something out put something else on
that again there's a dead and this so
sometimes you have to impose the
deadline but yeah I am the world's
biggest procrastinator some people
thrive on the pressure of the deadline I
think that's um right you I start to
write when I have to write so whenever
that deadline is that's what I'm started
are you doing thank you all right thank
you